good morning John President Trump
suggested a budget to the American
people yesterday let's try and
understand that budget quickly and
simply first there are a bunch of
programs like Medicare Medicaid
unemployment and Social Security that
would require much more work to change
and those are left untouched those
things and some other stuff called
mandatory spending takes up 73 percent
of the u.s. budget these blocks here
represent the 1 trillion 64 billion
dollars that is discretionary spending
in the US every block is a billion
dollars so there's 1,000 64 blocks on
this page let's look at how things stand
today keeping in mind that this is just
the 27 percent of the budget that is
discretionary about 590 blocks are the
military more than half the total Health
and Human Services is 84 blocks
Veterans Affairs is another 75 education
sixty-eight blocks
Housing and Urban Development 47
homeland security 41 state department
and international aid 38 energy 30
agriculture 23 blocks NASA 20
transportation 18 labor 12 Treasury
which is like the IRS and some other
stuff 12 blocks commerce 9 blocks the
EPA is 8 blocks the Corporation for
Public Broadcasting half a block and a
bunch of other tiniest stuff that adds
up a little bit so keeping in mind that
this is a suggested budget that will
change a great deal as it is turned into
law by Congress what do we see changing
the Trump budget increases the military
by 52 blocks a 10 percent increase
enough to pay for the entire current
budgets of the EPA the Corporation for
Public Broadcasting the Transportation
Department and NASA with some leftover
that money is slated to increase the
number of people serving in the Army and
the Marines and increase the number of
jet fighters and warships we have and
broadly to quote accelerate the war
against Isis four and a half lakhs go to
Veterans Affairs earmarked for health
care programs also increasing by about
three blocks as Homeland Security which
will be dedicated largely to border
control a full block and a half going to
detention and removal of undocumented
immigrants two and a half blocks going
to the down payment to build a big
beautiful wall you might have noticed
that that added up to more than three
blocks there are also some cuts within
Homeland Security mostly
counterterrorism stuff and that's it for
the increases now let's go through how
those things are paid for without
dramatically increasing the budget 13
blocks are going to come out of Health
and Human Services including the
low-income Home Energy Assistance
Program which basically helps poor
people stay warm in the winter but it
also
includes cutting six blocks out of the
National Institutes of Health for
biomedical research one of the largest
sources of research funding in the world
eleven blocks are to be eliminated from
the State Department international aid
will be largely gone climate change
initiatives at the UN would lose all
their funding and u.s. contributions to
UN peacekeeping would be reduced the
Department of Education loses more than
nine blocks which will eliminate college
scholarship programs for the poor
federal work-study programs and before
and after school programs for low-income
kids an increase of 1.5 billion dollars
within education would go to a private
school voucher program almost 5 lakhs
come out of a bunch of different
programs inside the Department of
Agriculture including international food
aid rural development and conservation
funding more than four blocks are
eliminated from Housing and Urban
Development which includes funding for
Meals on Wheels affordable housing and
anti-poverty programs 2.5 blocks come
out of the EPA a total of 30% of its
budget the hardest hit of any agency by
percent 3,200 jobs and 50 agencies would
go as well as funding for the clean
power plan regulations designed to curb
greenhouse gas emissions two and a half
blocks come out of the Labor Department
mostly by eliminating job programs for
seniors poor young people and the
unemployed 1.7 billion is taken out of
the Department of Energy the 1.4 billion
dollars of do a funding will also be
moved internally and put toward
increasing management of our nuclear
weapons arsenal decreases come out of
programs supporting development of
advanced and future clean energy
technology the Department of the
Interior loses a block and a half
funding that supports wildlife refuges
and national heritage areas and the
acquisition of new federally protected
land one block comes out of the
Department of Justice mostly because of
decreasing prison populations which is
actually good news all around and NASA
gets a small cut which comes almost
entirely out of the parts that study the
Earth's climate oh what's that little
block over there that's probably not
important right just one block that
contains oh yeah the entire National
Endowment for the Arts the National
Endowment for the Humanities the
Institute of Museum and Library Services
and the entire budget for the
Corporation for Public Broadcasting
which supports public TV and radio all
those things all together one block
under Trump's budget they don't exist
anymore that is basically very basically
because there are thousands of programs
within these departments and knowing
which ones do what is not going to fit
into a fun little youtube video but
basically what this budget asks for and
now it goes off to the House and Senate
to get argued about
tirelessly there is a lot in here that
many or even most think is worth
fighting for an enormous amount of lost
funding for scientific research both in
clean energy and medicine a lot of lost
funding for resources for the elderly
and disadvantaged populations an almost
wholesale elimination of international
aid and pretty much anything to do with
climate science is just gone
in reality Congress is going to have
huge problems with this budget and if
Trump's tax cuts are taken seriously
even with these budget cuts it will be
an extremely unbalanced budget that's
all I got I counted to a thousand a lot
today John I'll see you on Tuesday